hey everybody welcome to the first
episode of planet coaster college this
is a series in which i'll be making
tutorials for those of you who are
already familiar with the basic controls
and mechanics of the game but want to
delve deeper into more advanced uses of
them it's also for anybody who's stuck
trying to make a park with many ideas on
what to build but no way to successfully
translate that into the game or for
those who are just interested in the way
that I play it without the speed of my
usual time lapses I'll be going through
different aspects of making theme parks
like scenery buildings terraforming Park
layouts and of course coasters in
essence it's really for the sandbox mode
players who are looking into either the
creative or the realistic side of
playing the game now in this first
episode I'll be building and talking
about wooden roller coasters what
they're like in real life how you can
make them in the game and some general
rents with random tips and tricks so
without further ado let's get started
and build a classic wooden coaster now
right now if we want to build a wooden
rollercoaster we're going to have to
head over to the coaster section custom
and - wooden roller coasters which
there's only one of right now so that's
easy enough and place down the station
and I want to very quickly note here
that you always want to raise up the
station a little bit it just kind of
depends on what looks best or works best
in your case but they are usually raised
and either have just an empty room with
supports holding up the rest of the
station underneath them or in some cases
they have some electrical systems or
coaster mechanisms underneath there also
it kind of helps because if you want to
have a pre left section go down a little
bit before you actually go into the lift
till we have just enough Heights to have
that kind of thing basically you want to
make sure that your coaster isn't
entirely on the ground also I want to
very quickly note before we go on that
the trains on the wooden coaster here
are pretty important they might not look
that way but they kind of are these are
the very traditional standard six
coaster wooden coaster trains which you
see lots they're pretty much the most
common ones out there and you have them
both on very old classic traditional
wooden coasters as well as on some of
the modern ones I haven't really looked
into the details of what manufacturer
these are
but the important thing to keep in mind
here is that these are cosa trains with
pretty large cars and as you can see
they'll have like wheels on the front
and on the back of each car and that
means that these are not very flexible
you can't have tracks that twist around
a lot and change directions in a lot of
places so you want to keep the tracks
quite smooth and not make them change
like any kind of direction or banking in
very small sections and also you want to
be very careful with inversions and
generally avoid them with this kind of
wooden coaster and I would to be very
careful in saying this kind of thing
because inversions are wooden code on
wooden coasters are not unseen in
contrary to popular belief I suppose but
you want to be careful with these kinds
of things because there is actually a
pretty notorious example of a wooden
roller coaster with these trains that
had an inversion you might know it I'm
talking about son of Beast
and had a looping in it but it was so
brutal that it had to be taken down and
later the entire coaster had to be taken
down and just generally with this kind
of wooden coaster I wouldn't recommend
trying inversions that is usually done
with other types of winning coasters so
they're just usually left for other
types and that's probably a better idea
anyway let's get started with the
coaster layout itself and stop talking
about the type so much just want to keep
in mind that this is going to be a
somewhat smooth and not too twisty
wooden roller coaster and before I head
into the little I kind of wanted to go
down have a small curve before we go
there just the side note I'm going to be
coming up with the layouts of this
coaster along the way it's just going to
be improvisation and it's mostly about
the types of elements and the types of
things that you want to keep in mind
when you're building this kind of wooden
roller coaster instead of making the
best wooden roller coaster every right
here on the spot now you can see I'm
turning off I'm turning on angle snap
here because I want to go for a lift
Hill at about 30 degrees which is the
most common amount you do find a lot of
winning roller coasters which have just
a few less degrees left hill but about
thirty degrees is a pretty good
guideline and I wouldn't want to go too
far beyond that and let's see how
we can actually make this costume 20 to
see how tall it is right now I think we
can go just a little bit higher than
that say just about 30 meters I think
this is what this will be yep there we
go that's exactly 30 meters and this all
be the end of the little where I wanted
to go slightly down so that we can
release the coaster from the cable and
gravity will take it from that point
onward and we can head straight into the
first drop I would say at this point and
usually the first drop is of course the
tallest one especially in this case
where my terrain is just flats and I'm
going to build a pretty standard woody
so I want to make sure to go to the
ground and have a pretty nice and
intense first drop I think in this case
actually I'll make it quite steep wooden
rollercoaster don't usually have very
steep drops especially not that steep
but I usually make my heels a little bit
steeper than I want them to eventually
be since the smoothing tool takes out a
little bit of the steepness and
transitions it a bit after you smooth
the track so this would be a little bit
less deep as I smooth it out let me grab
the entire drop like that and just see
if I can smooth it out like that and
that should work fine and usually I also
like picking the individual parts of the
track to smooth out some parts so for
instance the transition here from the
drop into the horizontal part could be
smoothed out just a little bit more so
that's a bit wider and there we go I
think that's some pretty good shaping
now after this I am not really sure what
I'm gonna do but I think it's just time
to head into the second hill and make
that quite simple kind of go for a
standard kind of layouts on this coaster
so we're going to go up again and you
always want to make sure that the curve
is the largest at the bottom of the drop
where the coaster train is the fastest
generally the faster your train goes the
more you want your drops and your curves
to be very long and if it's very slow
you want to make the drop very short so
that you're still sort of pressed into
your seat and yeah I think that's just
about a good height so we can end the
top of the hill here
and here you can also see that the curve
of the top of the hill I want to make
that just a little bit less than the
curve down in the bottom here since it's
quite fast over here but I want to grab
some airtime like that moment where you
really fly out of your seats on the top
of the second hill here um though that
could be just a little bit smoother I
think let's make that a little bit
longer there we go and in the meantime
I'm going to want to see how this is
actually going to make it so let's start
a test and check the speed of the
coaster at that point in time I would
generally always advise to run a test
while you're building the coaster it's
going to make things a lot easier and
you'll never run into the issue where
you're building the coaster and then it
turns out that it doesn't actually make
it like that hill for example that's
just a little bit slower than I was
hoping for so I think I'll actually go
down a bit more here and also with Hills
just like the bottom of the first drop I
want to make it just a little bit taller
then I eventually wanted to be because
if you're grabbing the hill and you're
gonna smooth it out the smooth tool will
make it just a little bit shorter so I
usually make my things just a bit taller
then I really want them to be and let
the smooth tool take it from there
generally I don't want to leave any part
of the coaster track without having at
least touched it with a smoothing tool
and another very quick note that I do
want to give about it is that I usually
do have a mix between smoothing parts of
the track individually and smoothing
very large sections because if you
smooth out a large section the smoothing
tool is kind of going to find a sort of
baseline that it follows throughout that
section and smooth it all at once and
the kind of effect that it has on the
way that the track is going to go is
kind of like this say if I make a very
small hill and I grab the entire thing
and smooth it out at once the smooth
tool is eventually going to go towards
flattening this entire Hill and
stretching it out quite a lot so you
want to be very careful with doing that
too much let's bring it back down to the
shape that it was originally in and if I
really want to preserve the shape of
this hill and just kind of smooth out
the three
decisions around it then I want to grab
these pieces individually smooth out
these parts and you'll see that the
general shape of the hill is still there
while the different parts that I wanted
to be a bit more smooth I smooth out a
little bit more so usually I just kind
of use variation between smoothing out
very small sections and smoothing out
large sections there's no real way or
like wrong or right way to do that kind
of thing it just kind of depends on
whatever works best but generally I find
that it works best to just switch them
up both and use them pretty much
according to whatever works best in the
situation and at this point I think I
kind of want to go up again I suppose
that could be a little bit smoother so
let's take that out a bit and have
another Hill which is again of course a
little bit smaller than the past Hill at
this point I think I want to start going
down already and start going back to the
station because otherwise we might not
even make it and have a curve around
here which comes back on the back here
make that a little bit less steep than I
just had this is usually also the point
where I like to turn off angle snap just
because turning off angle snap gives you
a little bit more control in the curves
and the banks what I personally like in
wooden roller coasters is if you do have
a lot of variety in it of course this is
kind of subjective but most wooden
roller coasters that are generally found
to be the best to have a lot of variety
so you don't want it to be just Hills
until you enter the station you don't it
to be just curves but you kind of want
to switch it up so go from a hill into a
curve and back into the hill and just
have all of these different elements
that come after each other and in this
case I think I can still make that a
little bit more smooth actually have it
kind of go up like that think they'll be
fine yup there we go I'm looking for the
very standard look of a wooden roller
coaster obviously some of the things
that said wooden roller coasters apart
from other ones is that kind of feeling
of that you're out of control that the
train track is just kind of barging over
this wooden track of coaster which
doesn't really seem as say
as steel coasters and also you usually
they pack a lot of air time love these
places where you fly out of your seats
but another thing that makes wooden
coasters so special is of course the way
that they look so you want to make as
much use as you can of the look of these
wooden structures and that's also the
why I am laying it out like this so we
kind of have this hill that fills in the
gap between these two hills that maybe
after that we could have a few more
Hills and it basically you get this sort
of skyline and if you're walking around
the paths or save this with a car park
you would see this amazing looking
skyline of a wooden roller coaster
layouts and that's really what we're
looking for here you generally don't
want to make it too flat or too compact
and really show off all the curves and
the hills of the coaster as much as you
can especially the transitions so
whenever you go from a hill into a curve
or from a curve into another curve you
want to smooth those things as much as
you can because these things can be
quite rough and I think that looks quite
good speed on the entire thing is pretty
good as well you don't want it to slow
down too much on these hills so I'm
gonna go down there and maybe what I
think we could do is I'm starting to go
and try to weigh my options here we
could actually have another hill over
here but so far we already have a lot of
hills in this coaster so what I'm
thinking is that we can actually add
another typical wooden rollercoaster
elements I think this would be a pretty
cool place for a double-up yeah
basically double ups and double downs
are those kind of elements that you see
a lot of wooden roller coasters that are
quite a lot of fun
and something that you can always add to
a wooden roller coaster whenever there's
a bit of space where you're not really
sure what else to do or there's a very
large section where you only want to
have one hill and it basically does what
the name says you go up twice or you go
down twice so in this case I'm going to
add this little here over here and then
I'm going to add another hill and
that'll be pretty much the top where
it's gonna crest over now again I want
to smooth this out just enough so that
this
doesn't become one really curve I think
they'll be fine
could be banked a little bit more it's
also another thing to keep in mind is
that the smoothing tool if you select
very large sections it is going to get
rid of some of your banking so usually I
sort of read Bank it as I'm going
through it with this smoothing tool
there we go and smooth out this part of
the track if you're building double ups
and double downs though always be very
careful with the smoothing tool because
if you use it too much you're just going
to eventually remove the entire double
up or double down element in its energy
is going to be one straight section of
track which is pretty boring and not
what we're looking for here now we're
already getting into the second part of
the coaster and we've already lost half
of our speed but we do want to get the
feeling that the coaster doesn't really
lose any speed throughout the entire
layout we want to keep that momentum so
I think this last part of the coaster I
want to mostly focus on small twists and
turns and Hills instead of the large
winding hills that we have in the first
half so one of the first things that I'm
going to try in the second part is see
if we can get this quick curve in over
here just make that a little bit larger
thing just to smooth it out a bit more
these moving to will eventually take
care of that and make it look a bit
better than it currently does and after
that I'm looking into possibly making a
over banked curve over the lifter we
don't have an over-banked curve yet it's
basically one curve where you go up and
you're going to go straight at the top
of the hill and have a very steep Bank
so basically something like this and
then after this you go down again and
that is really where the very basic
over-banked curve looks like it's a
great way to curve around if you want to
have a hill in the mean time as well and
in this case especially I'm trying to
find a way around the lift over here and
this does so perfectly now this is also
the time that I usually go to the back
end of the station and add a straight
but very slightly inclined piece of
track at the end of it which is the
space for the break run would you need
to actually slow down the coast before
it enters the station or in some cases
to have a transfer track where you can
store the second train of the coaster so
with that out of the way we could pretty
much finish the layout of this wooden
coaster with a very low and twisty part
that makes its way back to the end of
that straight piece of track which you
could also curve a bit into a different
direction than the station I should say
you just want to make sure that you have
that straight break run just before you
enter the station also a little piece of
advice
most wooden coasters try to get as many
head choppers as they can which are
these moments when the supports or the
track above the track which you're
riding on are so close that you almost
feel like you're gonna have your head
hit by some wooden supports it never
really happens because obviously you
want it to be safe but these moments
kind of make the coaster seem faster and
more exciting a bit like where the
coaster goes underneath the supports
over here or where the coaster really
goes into the support structure at this
spot here I also put a Double Down
element over here so you can actually
fly out of your seat quite a bit more at
this ending element and make it seem a
little bit faster than it really is
because at this point the coaster is
pretty slow and I'm trying to make my
way back into the station without making
it seem as if the coaster is very slow
so that also means a lot of curves that
are very very close to the ground here
and switch it up quite a bit until we
get into the final helix that brings us
back into the brake run now with one
more curve at the end and a very small
hill this is actually the finished
layout of the coaster and what I haven't
really mentioned yet I will go over the
POV and the way it looks in a minute is
that this is really a sort of classical
out and back kind of wooden roller
coaster where you go out there all the
way to the other side of the map almost
turn around and have all of these
different hills and twists all the way
back to the station which is the way
that you see many of these especially
the traditional wooden roller coasters
where you really go somewhere else
almost explore like the parking lots or
explore the sides of the park which is
why you usually see these kinds of
courses as well now you do see some of
the more compact wooden roller coasters
that really twist in and out of
themselves which do more or less the
same thing as well just have love curves
overbank turns
double ups and downs small
time heals except instead of being very
spread out and thin in how they lay out
is laid out there much more twisting in
and out of themselves you can do both
things but in this case I really wanted
to go with a more traditional looking
wooden roller coaster and I'm actually
quite happy with how the skyline turn
now it's sort of having the hills in the
back fill in the gaps in the hills of
the fronts and with that over-banked
curve kind of nicely ending the skyline
of the coaster now you guys won't have a
POV of course so I'm going to very
quickly jump into the front seats and
I'm not going to be that kind of person
who is going to say we or anything else
on the coaster sure I'll do that in real
life but at this point I kind of want to
comment again on the way that different
parts of the coaster work so at this
point you're really pressed into the
cosa whereas on the top of that hill
just now you're really gonna fly into
the air out of your seats since it has
just enough time to glide over the hill
like that and the same thing goes over
here you just want the tops of those
hills to fly over it without slowing
down too much to catch that airtime and
the same kind of goes for the over
banked curves you want it to be just
fast enough to still be pressed in your
seats and we're almost there already and
the end of the coaster is very low just
so you don't really feel like you're
losing any speed which I wanted to go
for in this case and into the final
brake run to get slowed down that was a
little bit fast could have made the
brakes a bit more loose and slowed down
the coaster bit slower the most
important parts of the brake run at the
end in game is that we could actually
run two trains on it because of it
because there's a block brake and the
end of it we could actually turn on
block sections over here and put two
trains on the coaster which all make it
make quite a lot more money in the game
or in real life make a bit more
realistic whatever you're looking for
anyway that'll be all for this episode
of planet coaster college about wooden
roller coasters thank you guys so much
for watching and if you have any
questions or feedback don't be afraid to
leave it in the comment section and I'll
see you guys in the next video